Chris rufo you guys know Chris rufo he's
been on the show many many times from
the Manhattan Institute uh he's working
with Governor DeSantis here in Florida
to get wokeness out of all of our
colleges and institutions uh he has
uncovered a massive Scandal as it
relates to miss gay here we go here's a
tweet from Chris exclusive uh Chris
brunette and I have obtained
documentation demonstrating that Harvard
president Claudine gay plagiarized
multiple sections of her pH thesis
violating Harvard's policies on academic
Integrity Integrity this is a bombshell
first gay lifts an entire paragraph
nearly verbatim from a paper by Lawrence
Bobo and Franklin gilliams while passing
it as her own paraphrase and language
gay repeats this violation of Harvard's
policy throughout the document again
using work from Bobo and gillium as well
as passages from Richard shingle Susan
how and Deborah Fagan which she
reproduces nearly verbatim without
quotation marks second gay appears to
lift material from scholar Carol Swain
in one passage summarized the
summarizing the distinction between
descriptive representation and
substantive representation she copies
the phrasing and language nearly
verbatim from Swain's book Black Faces
black interests without providing a
citation of any kind third gay composes
an entire appendix in the dissertation
directly taken from Gary King's book a
solution to the ecological inference
problem while she cites King book while
she cites King's book later in the
appendix in fact King was her
dissertation advisor gay does not
explicitly acknowledge that appendix B
is entirely grounded in King's Concepts
and language instead passing it off as
her own original work these are flagrant
violations of Harvard's plagiarism
policy which states that students who
commit plagiarism will suffer
disciplinary action up to and including
requirement to withdraw from the college
the same standard should apply to the
university president uh let's go a
little deeper on this Aaron sibarium who
works with rufo uh he tweeted this scoop
rufo's examples are just the tip of the
iceberg in four articles published
between 1993 and 2017 including her
dissertation gay paraphrase or quoted
almost 20 authors without po proper
attribution in some cases lifting entire
paragraphs verbatim we worked with
nearly a dozen Scholars to analyze 29
potential cases of plagiarism most of
them said gay had violated a core
principle of academic Integrity plus
Harvard's own anti-plagiarism
policies which state that it's not
enough to change a few words here in
there rather Scholars are expected to
cite the sources of their work including
when paraphrasing and when to use
quotation marks when quoting directly
from others but in at least 10 instances
gay lifted full sentences even entire
paragraphs with just a work or two
tweaked in her 1997 thesis for example
she borrowed a full paragraph from a
paper by the scholars Bradley Palmquist
and then uh then a political science
professor at Harvard and Steven Voss one
of Gay's classmates in her PhD program
at Harvard while making only a couple
alterations so okay there's there's a
lot more on this they offer a lot more
evidence on this and you might say Okay
Dave why does this matter well the
reason it matters is that when you see
this woman who can't figure out whether
calling for genocide is against the
bullying and harassment policy of her
school and when you know that Harvard
has discriminated against Jews and white
people and Asian people and that is
baked into the code of Harvard
admissions um you might start thinking
have they hired the best and brightest
and why is it that we think of Harvard
as an elite school it's not just that
you think of Harvard as an elite school
Harvard is thought of as the elite of
the elite right if you said to nine out
of 10 Americans what's what's the best
college in America everyone just says
Harvard it's just the thing that's
become ubiquitous in our brains Harvard
is where all the smartest people go and
they'll have the best jobs and they'll
make the most money and live the most
prosperous successful lives but in fact
the stupidest people in our country run
our institutions and not only the
stupidest the most duplicitous who don't
even live up to the very standards that
they would let the students that they
would force the students live up to they
are a bunch of
frauds